while we wait for the A's to announce
their next steps in moving to Las Vegas
the topic came up at today's Stadium
Authority board meeting the chair of
that board says it will have a hand in
the decision making for a new stadium
eight news now investigator Kyle Payne
was at the meeting has some new
information Kyle Brian details have been
awfully slow to come this week but today
we learned the chairman of the stadium
Advisory Board is in Carson City for the
sole purpose of dealing with the A's one
member of the public spoke at the
meeting wondering why the A's had to
come to the strip at all he also
criticized the size of the stadium which
would be one of the smallest in Major
League Baseball the proposed Stadium
would hold about 20 000 people less than
the A's current Stadium meantime if this
moves forward the board has its hands
full just like they did when the Raiders
chose Las Vegas
the stadium Authority will have
similar oversight
over that Stadium as it does with the
legion stadium so it would be the
stadium authorities
responsibility to negotiate development
agreements and leases the legislature is
in session until June 5th but a bill
isn't expected to be introduced until
next week today I also spoke with the
president of local 872 who is also in
the stadium Authority board he says the
union is showing its support of the move
by planning a trip to Carson City
they're going to paint the town in A's
colors green and yellow hanging banners
wherever they can just like they did a
few years ago back when the legislature
was voting on the Raiders to come here
to Las Vegas